i mean we have different views sometimes
but
that's my husband you know kim
kardashian and kanye west are putting
their kids first
despite their alleged marriage troubles
it's extremely important to me
a source tells e.t that the 40 year old
reality star and the 43 year old rapper
might be ending their romantic
relationship but are still on good terms
when it comes to the four
kids they share seven-year-old north
five-year-old saint
three-year-old chicago and one-year-old
psalm
kim and kanye are still heading for
divorce the couple hasn't seen each
other much lately but still communicate
regularly
kim continues to live in calabasas and
kanye is spending time
in and out of wyoming having kids is
just there's no way to describe it but
it's
a lot as for the kids e.t soar says they
don't know much of what's going on
because they are young but also
this isn't new to them kim and kanye
have always been
so busy traveling and in and out that
kanye not being there
isn't shocking at the end of the day kim
and kanye will do what is best for their
kids and are on great terms as parents
we love each other's opinions and we
definitely rely on each other for
each other's opinions a source
previously told et that kim has been
done with her marriage to kanye since
july when she had an emotional visit
with him at their wyoming ranch
following his controversial political
rally in south carolina
where he talked about having an abortion
when she was pregnant with their first
child
north so even if my wife were to divorce
me
after this speech she brought north into
the world even when i didn't want to
she stood up and she protected that
child kanye went on a subsequent twitter
rant of since deleted comments about his
wife
and her family you know he might say
things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind
it but i always know his heart earlier
this month a separate source opened up
to et about the final straw between the
couple
and explained how kim is prioritizing
their family and
kanye's well-being her last real attempt
to make their relationship
work was when she flew to wyoming in
july and she was seen crying in the car
with him
after that she just knew that she had to
be done for good
kim has been over kanye in a romantic
sense for a while
but loves him as the father of their
kids and
doesn't want to embarrass or hurt him
you